what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to spin
ben's
beatbox remix before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring the notification
bell i have never seen this video before
but i'm kind of excited because this guy
i can see it in the beginning he's like
standing on top of a car
and i i feel like it's kind of cool
go go go oh damn
god spin
spin what you're cooking 19
shooters
[Music]
what does it mean if you say he ain't
cut
your accent yeah what does that mean
he ain't cut yeah use it in the census
he used
i can't why because i'm white
all right let me listen again
[Music]
okay so he's talking about sweeping the
block and so what that means is like
if you're in downtown like chicago or
like
any city right i'm from chicago i use
chicago there's like this like
a block right like where you live
whatever so what he's doing is he's
taking like um
a like a broom and like sweeping it
because sometimes there's like duh
no no no no why did i know you was gonna
go down that road that's not what the
[ __ ] it is
what does it mean oh my god
are you gonna tell me or you're just
gonna interrupt my video it means
he gonna shoot everybody
what if there's like a kid walking ain't
nobody getting spared
okay well spinvens does not seem like a
nice man
he doesn't if that's what he's doing
kids and women and everyone
okay so he said bust soon as i see op so
i know what this means this means
if there's an opposition right and he's
gonna bust and what that means is like
to shoot them so if he sees an
opposition
bang they're dead okay all right
oh okay this was clever so she said
their video is the only thing getting
shot so he's saying his opposition
they're shooting videos they're talking
but they don't have the balls to shoot
i mean personally i wouldn't really
encourage people that don't like me to
shoot at me
like that's just me um call me
old-fashioned
but you know to each his own
[Music]
oh my gosh that was so rude
he said this guy died right and then
he's saying
that the mom cried
that is so disrespectful that is not
nice
that is not nice at
that was all he said he could spot his
ops from anywhere because he's got three
eyes so he's saying like
if he had a third eye he could like see
his opposition from super far away
why are you laughing
why are you laughing leave me out of
this bro
i think you you you interrupted the
video
like what are you talking about
[Music]
oh my gosh so he's saying like that he
killed this guy's brother
and he's saying you should have died too
what
this this is mad disrespectful i will
say though i will say this though he has
a turtleneck with the gold
and i love me a good turtleneck so
even with all the disrespect
that he's throwing the shade talking
about marks
still fire nevertheless look i got an
outfit like that
and i look pretty good in it i'm not
gonna lie
i'm gonna continue
[Applause]
wait what does that mean to put dead ops
in your cover
oh my god he means the song
oh my gosh so he's gonna put people that
like died
like does that mean if someone has an
opposition does that mean like they're
automatically in a gang but so i'm
guessing like his gang
killed their gangs like people and now
he's gonna put him in his music
would i be mad if i died and someone put
me in a song
i don't think i'd really care honestly
i'm dead right damn he got dead
in this cup be the first [ __ ] to drink
that ups everybody has to be smoking
that up
[ __ ] double dose this [ __ ] smoking
and drinking the odds
oh and now he's just spilling the drink
for no
reason that's wasteful wasteful
okay guys i thought this was an
interesting video
on a scale of one to five as you guys
know i'm switching from
a one to ten scale to a one to five i
think it's more efficient
i'm gonna give this a two out of five
because it just talked about killing a
little too much for me
however i really did enjoy the turtle
deck so that's why i didn't give it like
a one i give it
two maybe almost a three but let me know
in the comments what you guys would rank
the song scale one to five
now one to ten and also do not forget to
subscribe
to the channel and ring the notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos